tomemos varios números y multipliquemos
los con esto encontraremos varias cosas
interesantes primero creo que
encontremos cuánto es 4 por 5 por 2 paus
el vídeo e intenta encontrar el
resultado
bien cualquiera que haya sido tu
resultado estoy seguro de que algunos de
ustedes lo hicieron de esta forma
multiplicaron 4 por 5 después ese
resultado lo multiplicaron por 2 es
decir algunos lo que hicieron en primer
lugar fue multiplicar 4 por 5 por eso
puse este paréntesis alrededor de esta
multiplicación y después lo
multiplicaron por 2 y que obtuvieron
bueno la primera parte 4 por 5 claro que
les dio 20 después multiplicaron por dos
y obtuvieron 40 lo cual es correcto 4
por 5 por 2 es 40 ahora lo que quiero
que hagas a continuación es que me digas
lo más rápido posible cuánto es 5 por 2
por cuatro venga muy rápido pagos el
vídeo cuánto es cinco por dos por cuatro
bueno estoy seguro de que algunos de
ustedes lo hicieron de una forma similar
a la anterior primero encontraron el
resultado de 5 por 2 5 por 2 días
después lo multiplicaron por 4 así
obtuvieron de nuevo 40 lo mismo que en
el ejercicio pasado algo interesante
está sucediendo aquí tal vez de lo que
te diste cuenta es de que en ambos casos
estamos multiplicando los mismos tres
números solo que cambiamos el orden los
escribimos en diferente orden observan 4
por 5 por 2 ya camps 5 por 2 por 4
aquí hicimos primero 4 por 5 y acá
hicimos primero 5 por 2 pero observa
llegamos al mismo resultado y ahora te
voy a encargar de nuevo que pausas el
vídeo e intentas multiplicar estos
números en cualquier orden que se te
ocurra puede ser primero 2 por 4 y
después por 5 es más vamos a hacer
primero 2 por 4 y después por 5 cuál
será este resultado bueno ahora me
puedes decir que esto es
824 es 8 y 8 por 5 de nuevo es 40
creo que ya observa este un patrón por
aquí no importa en qué orden multiplique
los números puedes escribir 4 por 5 por
2 días el primero 4 por 5 y después por
2 o puedes hacerlo de esta manera 4 por
5 por 2 porque no importa cómo
desarrolles esta multiplicación en todos
los casos obtendrás 40 y esta propiedad
tiene un nombre muy elegante
esta es la propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación esto no sólo es cierto
con tres números pasa lo mismo con dos
números ya que no importa en qué orden
los multiplique y pasará lo mismo con
cuatro números o con cinco números o con
mil números que se multipliquen entre
todos
si todos se multiplican entre 100 no
importa el orden en el que se
multipliquen
es decir no importa en qué orden los
asocies aquí hicimos primero 4 por 5 ya
que hicimos primero 5 por 2 pero en
ambos casos obtuvimos el mismo resultado
al acabar este vídeo te encargo que
pienses porque es cierto esto en este
mundo que te cuestiones el por qué
funciona esta propiedad es muy agradable
porque esta propiedad no simplifica la
vida cuando hacemos matemáticas no solo
ahora también en todo nuestro estudio de
las matemáticas por ahora este es el
final hasta la próxima